alright guys so welcome to this uh
live market update uh live because i'm
live but unfortunately the market is not
open yet i'm still in hong kong moving
at the end of the month guys
so um
i wanted to make this update because we
had a pretty bad day yesterday
uh hey bro what's up
uh on
most of meme stocks you know on amc gme
so i'm gonna go of course through those
two uh some other stocks actually hold
pretty well like uh fisell which we are
in
um i also want to talk about blnk uh
that had a very interesting move up two
days ago that got then
that just it wasn't just a pullback i
think hey jacob what's up bro hey bro
amc to the moon yes but maybe not right
now we're gonna discuss this
um so as usual guys i'm gonna keep an
eye uh on the chat and whenever i see
some stocks that you guys want me to
analyze i'm gonna go to it
um
but let's start with amc and gamestop
because i know that those two are very
important they are to me actually
um
the
you know they represent the apes
movement you know that's it so they are
just like indices you know
just like the s p 500 the nasdaq so of
course they're smaller but compared to
the other meme stock market
capitalization they are actually quite
big we're talking around uh 20 billion
usd for each
uh which is a lot hey brother what's up
so um
so i think that basically checking the
flows that go in and out of those two is
a very good information about what can
happen with the other uh meme stocks
um
so let's analyze that we had a pretty
bad day so i think everything is
starting from amc so as you guys know we
had earnings um announced yesterday
i mean two days ago on the 8th of
november
so sorry just one sec
okay
so uh let's check what those earnings
were so i'm going on bloomberg
um
and i just want to show you guys that
the earnings were good you know so e r n
sorry it's not the slot
okay let's see
okay so this is bloomberg and you can
see that
here
the expected earnings of the third
quarter announced on the 8th of november
were
supposed to be minus 53 cents per share
and they were better than that they were
minus 44. so we still expect we still
had negative earnings just as expected
but less negative than analysts were
thinking so this is a positive surprise
as you can see plus 17 percent so we had
basically good news
um
so i think that this is actually a nice
example
to illustrate what often happens uh on
on the market it's not on amc or gme on
only on meme stocks this is a saying
that we have in finance
for um most of stocks or even indices it
is by the rumor sell the news and this
is exactly what happened here
so basically
it's been one week investors are
preparing to get this news so as you can
see guys i'm on a daily timeframe here
and
the past 10 days were actually bullish
you know we came close to this
major resistance level that was here
whenever you see the price action going
higher like this it's always important
to check what is the volume doing but
guys the volume was going higher too
so
i mean
you know sometimes
when you do an analysis and then you see
that actually things didn't go the way
you you were thinking
you check
again and sometimes see some signals
that you could have used but in this
case
there are almost
no bearish signals that i that could
have been used to anticipate what
happened here
so um so this is a very i would say pure
fake out why is it a pure fake out
because as you guys can see investors
were buying here once again on the rumor
about good results and we had here a
daily close above this blue trend line
that i get connect by connecting the
highs that are here and it was also the
recent uh high that we had in october so
this 44 level was very important
i will talk about nioh just after of
course
um
so here we went above that level with
volume and we did a new high so this is
the definition of
um a breakout and it's also suggesting
that we have we are going to have a
reversal whenever you see for the first
time in six months high high you know
this didn't happen for you know this
whole period that was a corrective
period and here we had it
so to me you know it was a very good
signal we were above the moving averages
so everything was looking perfect here
uh we had the good news the results the
volume increase so i mean you know
sometimes this just happens ca here uh
could not i mean at least using my tools
i don't see any signal that could have
to tell us what would happen the only
uh thing we could have used is this
saying that is once again by the rumors
sell the news and just after the news
investors just got out of this trade um
and
and probably put their money somewhere
else where some news is coming so what
is the situation right now because this
is what we are wondering um
i'm going to zoom in a little bit
so i'm going to go on the first time
frame
and we are still for now in this
scenario to me that is intact uh hey
brother
yes yes bull trap this is yeah exactly
this is a fake out this is a bull trap
um
the only thing we can say is that you
know whenever we have a breakout uh so i
personally like to trade the first
candle otherwise you might be late but
um to be 100 sure and this is what i was
saying on my discord in my daily recap
on amc we need to wait a second candle
to close above the breakout level and
you can see that even on the first time
frame we didn't have it so basically
this breakout was actually very quick
let's see for how long did we manage to
stay actually there
if i'm gonna hourly time frame one two
three okay we stayed three hours above
that level
so not even a full four hour candle
so for this reason this breakout was not
strong enough to hold for now
so i'm coming back to my scenario what
can happen from here so i think that
this triangle abcde
is still good we are of course still in
a triangle
um i'm not sure i'm gonna
you know update my trend line or not
you know let me see if i can find
something that is fitting better
you see maybe we need to do this kind of
trendline from now on
you know this is the issue when you
whenever you have a fake out then the
breakout level is not clean anymore and
we need to find a new area
where this breakout can happen again so
i'm gonna use this trendline and for now
let's assume this scenario is still on
the table
so you guys know
that uh in this kind of situation
um
we can use elliott way theory and
fibonacci so just one sec
it seems like my battery
is not very well loaded all right but i
hope it's gonna work if i'm
out guys of the live it means i had some
issues with my computer but i hope it
will hold
so here we can measure the second wave
this is the first information we can use
once again guys i invite you to go check
this out so you type elliot with yuri
frost and prashta you guys know this is
my bible
this is a very interesting book that i
encourage all of you to read
and in here whenever you go i know i
showed you guys this many times but it's
still important to
see it again
okay page 78 guys
okay and here you can see that second
waves they usually go to the 61.8
retracement of wave one so
uh
we know that this is a first wave i mean
this is what we're gonna assume
so because this would be the wave that
is actually the first wave of the
reversal so it's a typical first wave
and uh we're gonna measure the size of
this first wave
and see where is the 61.8 retracement
and it is at
39
yeah all right the video stream is laggy
i can see it too
uh there's nothing much i can do for
that so i just hope it's gonna be better
um
[Music]
you choose interesting
okay it seems like indeed my stream is a
bit slow
um i'm gonna stick to that and if it's
not going better in a few minutes i'll
just restart it
so here
um once again we are wondering how low
the second wave can go so we're going to
use the 61.8 retracement of fibs
and
this is giving us 39 as a level so we
have a first support at 39
then we can check let's go back on the
daily time frame
hey morning brother from poland chesh
check shamash adam
all right
so um
the second wave
can go we said to 39 we also have on the
daily time frame i prefer to use moving
averages from the daily time frame
because they are
giving usually better reactions
um
so
so here uh
we have the 20 period moving average
coming at 39 so this would be the level
that makes the most sense to me
uh the pre-market has just started it's
rather flattish
all right
so um
so 39 should hold and let's right away
see the alternative scenario guys
which is
yes sorry them
okay the alternative scenario is that is
just that our um
e-wave is actually a bit longer
all right give me a sec
okay how is the
the video guys can you tell me in the
comments is it better the quality or is
it still lagging
okay
okay okay okay well let me let me keep
doing that and let's see if it doesn't
go better once again i will just stop it
and redo another one so here the
alternative scenario guys is that the
e-wave is actually not
finished here but that the e-wave is
slightly uh going further
so
in this scenario um we might even go to
lower levels like 37 so i would say that
the support area is 37.39 if we hold
above 39 it means that we are in this
scenario one two three and that we're
gonna have a massive third wave coming
this is of course on the table and if we
go below 39 then it's probably not to
one two it means probably that we have a
new wave that is longer
this video is still laggy okay i'm just
gonna finish on amc and then i'm just
gonna restart my computer and hope this
will be better
um let me finish this scenario so if we
go below 39 it means that we would
probably have a consolidation period
around
here you know and then start again the
new cycle one two three four five all
right so this would not change a lot the
overall
uh the outcome the final outcome
would still have something like this um
but it would just delay it so carefully
if you have options here we lost to me
one week or maybe even one month uh to
the um first scenario where we reached
the target quicker um
so once again i think that 37 29 is a
good area to get in um and we need right
now to you know do this breakout again
so
44 is probably still going to be the
level to break above but now we have
this new height here so basically we
would need to see a close above
this high was at 46 right now so we need
a full day trading above 46 to um
to make sure the bears are
uh
ready letting it go
uh all right guys so i have some issues
i think with my uh videos i'm just gonna
stop this live here and i'm going to
start again very soon where i'm going to
discuss gme blnk riot fiscal everything
you guys want me to talk about so see
you